Let's quickly review what
we've learned about arrays.
We learned that arrays
are ordered lists of items and
that they can have duplicates.
For example,
here's my array of favorite things and
you can see that raindrops on roses
appears twice and that's totally okay.
Because arrays are ordered we're
able to access its items by index.
You can see here that we're accessing
the first item with the index zero.
And we're accessing the fourth
item with the index three.
We also went over three different
ways to initialize an array.
First, using somewhat verbose syntax,
second by specifying the item type
between square brackets, and
third using an array literal.
We also saw that in Swift,
arrays have types.
Meaning that they can hold
any type you desire, but
they can't hold two items
that have different types.
For example,
I can't add a variable of type string
to an array of type light switch.
We also practiced using
Array operations,
let's see those one more time.
Here I have an array of musicians, and
I can append an artist to the end of my
musicians array using the method append.
And I can insert another artist at
a particular index using insert atIndex.
And over here you can see
Dej Loaf at index two.
To remove an item from the array,
I use removeAtIndex.
If I remove the item at index three,
you can see Flo Rida is removed.
If I want to know how many items are in
my array, I use the count method.
Right now, I've got five.
And finally, if I want to retrieve and
item at a particular index.
I can use subscript syntax, like so.
And here we can see the third
item is "Dej Loaf".
We also went over copying and
concatenating arrays.
Array concatenation in
Swift is super convenient.
We just use the plus operator and
we're good to go.
To copy an array,
we just define our copy to be equal
to the value of the original.
Arrays are value types,
which means that here array and
arrayCopy represent
two distinct entities.
If I change a value in arrayCopy,
you can see that the values
in array remain the same.
There are exceptions to this.
Which you'll learn more about
in this session on classes.
And finally,
we talked about how to use fast
enumeration to loop through an array.
For-in loops take the general form,
four item in collection and
then between curly braces,
the statement that you want to execute
on each item in the collection.
For example, to find the sum of all
the n's in this array we just type for
value in int array and
this statement adding
int to the sum will be executed for
each member of the collection.
You can see in the playground
sidebar that this statement is being
executed five times.
And here we can see the sum.